Okay, let's talk about the economy today.
Um, Donald Trump has been touting the current
economy as the best ever.
Trump has been bragging about how strong the
economy is in general. He says it's the best
it's ever been for black Americans, the best
that's ever been for Hispanic Americans. And
he usually points to unemployment rates and
the stock market being high. And yet at the
same time, 40% of the population is still
struggling just to pay their basic bills every
single month, which is more than a hundred
million people in this country. How is it
possible that we have the best economy ever?
And 40% of the population is struggling to
pay their bills? And to really understand
this, you actually have to zoom out because
it's bigger than Trump. Of course, when Trump
says something like, this is the best economy
ever. It's meaningless political hyperbole.
But there's a deeper analysis to be done here
that is beyond left right politics, or at
least it's beyond Donald Trump. So let's do
it.
It's true that the economic expansion that
the US has seen, dating back to the beginning
of Barack Obama's presidency is on paper the
longest economic expansion in the history
of the United States of America. That's true.
As defined as as as we define expansions and
still we know that a huge portion of the country
can't even afford an unexpected $400 emergency
expense. How is it possible that both are
true? The stock market is at record highs.
The unemployment rate is historically at it's
lows, and yet there are a record number of
people who are 90 days or more behind on car
payments, which is a concerning indicator
that can predict economic trouble and that
number continues to climb every single month.
That's not good. How can there be on c a signals
on paper that things are so good and at the
same time, nearly half the country can't pay
its bills?
And the answer effectively boils down to one
word. If we need to boil it down to one word
and that word is inequality. It's a little
simplistic, but in a sense it's all about
that one word. Inequality. I'll explain the
economic expansion. Dating back to Obama has
been hugely unequal. The gains in the stock
market that we've seen dating back to Obama
are a hugely concentrated in a very small
portion of the population that owns the vast
majority of the stock. So for a huge number
of people, even though on paper the stock
market is way, way, way up, it does very little
for a huge number of people that don't own
any or almost any shares of stock wage growth
wage has gone mostly to the upper tier net
worth growth has gone mostly to the upper
tier, stagnant wages on the lower tier.
So again, on paper you can come up with broad
averages that look good or at least look okay.
But for a huge portion of the country, cost
of living has continued to go up, but their
inflation adjusted wages have not. So they
can't pay their bills even though on paper
they should be okay. Unemployment is low and
the stock market is high, just as very little
for a lot of the people living in the United
States of America. So when you go all the
way back to 1989 30 years ago, the bottom
half of the country is less wealthy today.
Inflation adjusted than they were 30 years
ago. This is stunning given the economic growth
that in total the United States has seen in
the last 30 years and the explanation is inequality
or specifically unequal growth in almost every
aspect of the United States economy. And the
problem with this is that the economy is in
a sense hanging by a thread, even though so
many numbers look good.
As Donald Trump talks about, there are like
100 million people in this country for whom
even a mild economic setback in the broader
economy can push them into a completely unsustainable
financial situation. This could include a
bankruptcy, this could include having to rack
up crushing credit card debt at high interest.
This could include a home foreclosure or an
eviction from a place that they rent, vehicle
repossession, and of course remember that
in the back of our minds is the possibility
that a medical bill could bankrupt us completely.
Our health insurance system fundamentally
weakens the economy because of the system
that we have. People who are even in an okay
financial position are still at risk of losing
everything because of unexpected medical bills
that may not be covered by their insurance.
That's how the system works. That's how the
country works, which sheds a lot of light
on the reality that our health insurance system
is an economic liability beyond just being
a moral and ethical liability.
So the thing about all of this is that because
these things are so political, each president,
each party, they always want to take credit
for any wins they can take credit for. They
want to shirk responsibility for any of the
losses that they can successfully shirk responsibility
for that. We end up unable to have the real
serious conversation. As a result, this is
actually bigger than Republicans and Democrats
and now it's true. It's not totally apolitical.
It's true that historically Democrats are
better than Republicans in terms of stock
market returns, but that doesn't affect everybody
equally. It's true that historically Democrats
are better than Republicans in terms of the
average unemployment rate during their presidency.
But that doesn't actually tell us whether
people are making a living wage or whether
they have to work multiple jobs in order to
make ends meet by the standards we use.
Democrats are better than Republicans, but
unfortunately those standards fall very, very
short and these are just bigger that don't
even enter into the political election cycles
that we have of two, four and six years, two
years for the House of Representatives, four
years for the president and six years for
the u s Senate respectively. Automation and
technological unemployment is one of those
issues. Inequality is another one of those
issues. Education costs are another issue
that around the margins you will hear Poe,
politicians talk about, but nothing serious
has been done to deal with that. The health
care system. Fortunately it's entering more
into the political discussion, particularly
since the, uh, since 2010 and Obamacare, uh,
and Bernie Sanders mainstreaming the idea
of Medicare for all in 2016. But this is why
you hear the economy is the best ever, and
there are actually some numbers that sort
of seem to reflect that in some way, but yet
almost half the country is hanging by a thread
that's not going to change. Listen, if the
stock market, if the Dow goes to 30,000 still
a huge portion of the country will be at risk
of a $400 unexpected expense, throwing their
financial situation into total disrepair.
Uh, you are not going to change that if the
unemployment rate goes from 3.8 to 3.7%. Okay?
These are bigger systemic issues and inequality.
If I had to sum it up in one word, tells us
a lot about why this is the case. Let me know
what you think. I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is
on twitter@davidpakmanshow